the British commuters it's a case of New
Year same strikes tens of thousands of
rail workers from the rmt union began a
two-day walkout on Tuesday kicking off a
five-day run of industrial action across
the rail network this first strike
leaving a skeleton service in some parts
of the country none at all in others um
it has been really hectic especially
getting to work has been really
difficult
but fortunately again you know with
technology it does help that we can work
from home so I completely understand
that people have the right to strike and
I support them it's obviously
frustrating after coming back from
Christmas the last thing you want to do
is then have delay travel trains are
still running particularly at major city
hubs like this one but they're running
at about 20 percent of normal capacity
starting later and finishing earlier in
the day passengers are being told not to
travel at all if possible those who are
making Journeys having to plan
accordingly the unions want pay awards
that reflect inflation currently running
at nearly 11 percent and their resisting
proposed changes to working conditions
including more driver-only trains and
more mandatory Sunday working our
members working lives will be thrown up
in the air and their conditions will be
ripped to pieces they have voted no to
that and not it wasn't even first in
their their thinking about pay hundreds
of our members have been in contact
saying don't throw our conditions away
in return for a very modest pay deal the
government rejects the Union's charge
that it's preventing the rail companies
from making a deal at the same time
insisting inflation-matching pay Awards
would harm the economy there's a fair
and reasonable payoff on the table which
two of the trade unions have accepted
the rmt sadly decided to reject it it
has to be an offer that's fair and
reasonable for the taxpayer as well as
for the people that work in industry and
we've also got to see some reform in the
way the industry operates so that we
have a proper seven-day Railway that
passengers can rely on Network rail
which runs and maintains the tracks says
such a deal is within touching distance
there are reports that improve benefits
rather than pay are under consideration
for now though this winter of strikes
and disruption rolls on Harry Fawcett Al
Jazeera London